STOP RAISING MONEY OFF LYING
ABOUT ME BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT
YOU'RE DOING.
HERE WITH REACTION, FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR, FORMER SPEAKER OF
THE HOUSE NEWT GINGRICH.
HE DOES REPRESENT VERY WELL I
THINK THIS NEW, ENDORSED BY AOC,
ENDORSED BY THE SQUAD, BERNIE.
BERNIE ENDORSED HIM.
ABORTION WITH NO RESTRICTIONS
WHATSOEVER, FRACKING, ENERGY
PRODUCTION.
HE REALLY DOES FIT IN WITH THE
CLIMATE ALARMIST CULT.
HE IS LIKE THE POSTER CHILD FOR
THEM.
>> IF YOU LOOK AT HIS POSITIONS,
HE IS PROBABLY MORE RADICAL THAN
ALMOST ANY DEMOCRAT IN THE
SENATE BECAUSE HE IS EVEN MORE
RADICAL THAN BERNIE SANDERS.
NEXT GENERATION OF RADICALISM.
IF YOU WATCH HIS CAMPAIGN,
YOU'LL SEE SOMETHING YOU'RE
GOING TO SEE ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY.
NONE OF THESE PEOPLE CAN DEFEND
THEIR RECORD.
NONE OF THEM CAN DEFEND
JOE BIDEN.
NBC NEWS REPORTED THIS MORNING
THAT HE IS THE MOST UNPOPULAR
PRESIDENT IN 80 YEARS.
MORE THAN 3 OUT OF 4 AMERICANS
BELIEVE WE ARE ALL THE WRONG
TRACK.
SO GUYS WHO HAVE DONE NOTHING
THE WHOLE LIFE EXCEPT POLITICS,
THAT'S WHAT FETTERMAN'S, CAREER
POLITICIAN, HE'S NEVER DONE
ANYTHING IN THE PRIVATE SECTOR
THAT MATTERS, HAS NO
UNDERSTANDING OF IT.
HE HAS GOT TO PLAY GAMES, HE'S
GOT TO DANCE AROUND DR. OZ, FIND
GIMMICKS.
IF HE GETS PINNED AS YOU JESTED
TO HIS ROOM RECORD, HE'S GONE.
IT'S HOPELESS.
PENNSYLVANIANS AREN'T GOING TO
VOTE TO LEGALIZE HEROIN.
THEY ARE NOT GOING TO VOTE TO
DESTROY WESTERN PENNSYLVANIA'S
ENERGY INDUSTRY.
FOURTH BIGGEST ENERGY PRODUCER
IN THE UNITED STATES IS
PENNSYLVANIA.
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO VOTE FOR
SOMEBODY WHO KEEPS RELEASING
MURDERERS, RAPISTS, ARMED
ROBBERS.
ON EVERY REAL ISSUE I THINK
FETTERMAN HAS A PROBLEM BUT HE
IS TYPICAL OF WHAT WE ARE SEEING
AROUND THE COUNTRY.
IN GEORGIA, YOU HAVE WARNOCK WHO
WAS VOTED OVERWHELMINGLY WITH
JOE BIDEN AT A TIME ONE IN
GEORGIA, BIDEN IS DOWN IN THE
LOW 30s.
IF IT BECOMES A WARNOCK-BIDEN
VOTE, WARNOCK DOESN'T HAVE A
CHANCE OF COMING BACK.
THE SAME THING WITH KELLY IN
ARIZONA.
THEY HAVE HAD OVER A 200 OPIOID
DEATHS.
THEY HAVE HAD HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE ACROSS THE
BORDER.
DOES KELLY FIGHT TO GET MORE
BORDER AGENTS?
NO.
HE VOTES FOR 87,000 NEW IRS
AGENTS TO CONTROL US, THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, NOT ANY EXTRA
BORDER AGENTS TO CONTROL ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS.
KELLY TRYING TO FIND THAT --
DEFEND THAT AN ESTATE IS OVERRUN
WITH THE CONSEQUENT CIVIL LEGAL
IMMIGRANTS, THEY ARE SAYING IN
RACE AFTER RACE AROUND THE
COUNTRY, DEMOCRATS CANNOT DEBATE
THE ISSUES.
THEY CANNOT DEFEND THEIR VOTES.
THEY TRY GIMMICKS TO TRY TO KEEP
THE REPUBLICANS OFF BALANCE.
>> Sean: NO RESTRICTIONS AT
ALL OR LIMITS ON ABORTION.
COMPLETE MORATORIUM, IN
PENNSYLVANIA ON FRACKING, THIS
IS INSANITY.
SANCTUARY CITIES, HE SUPPORTED
THAT POLICY.
SUPPORT OF THE $1.9 TRILLION
STIMULUS.
SUPPORTED THE MANCHIN-SCHUMER
DEAL.
CHASES AN INNOCENT MAN, A
MINORITY DOWN THE BLOCK AND PUTS
A SHOTGUN IN THIS INNOCENT GUY'S
FACE.
TELL ME ONE REPUBLICAN THAT MAY
EVER DO SUCH A THING.
AND NOT HAVE THE SCRUTINY THAT
DESERVES.
>> IT'S AMAZING THAT
BARACK OBAMA WHO IS VERY
SENSITIVE ABOUT THESE ISSUES FOR
FIVE YEARS AGO WAS NEVER SAID
ANYTHING ABOUT FETTERMAN.
HE HAD A SHOTGUN AND HE HELD
THIS GUY WITH A SHOTGUN TO THE
POLICE CAME AND THAT IT TURNED
OUT OF THE GUY WAS AN INNOCENT
JOGGER OUT EXERCISING.
SO IT'S KIND OF WEIRD.
I THINK HE GOES DEEPER THAN
THAT.
WHAT YOU HAVE TODAY OUTSIDE OF
MAYBE THE UNIVERSITY OF
PENNSYLVANIA FACULTY, YOU HAVE
IN FETTERMAN, SO MANY --
SOMEBODY SO RADICAL HE CAN'T
POSSIBLY REPRESENT THE PEOPLE OF
PENNSYLVANIA.
I THINK THAT'S WHAT MAKES ALL OF
THIS DANGEROUS.
WE SAW THIS IN WYOMING WHERE LIZ
CHENEY WAS REPUDIATED GETTING
ONLY 29% OF THE VOTE.
IT'S BECAUSE YOU HAVE THIS
GROWING GAP.
I SUSPECT THE AVERAGE
PENNSYLVANIA LOOKS AT DR. OZ'S
REAL RECORD, LOOKS AT
FETTERMAN'S REAL RECORD AND
ASKS, WHICH PERSON IS GOING TO
FIGHT FOR PENNSYLVANIA IN THE
U.S. SENATE, I HAVE A HUNCH THAT
OZ IS GOING TO WIN A
SURPRISINGLY BIG VICTORY BECAUSE
THERE'S NO EVIDENCE THAT
FETTERMAN, OTHER THAN BEING FOR
LEGALIZATION OF MARIJUANA AND
HEROIN ON SETTING UP DRUG
CENTERS AROUND THE COUNTRY AND
CITIES, PAID FOR BY THE
TAXPAYERS TO GO GET YOUR SHOT
FROM A GOVERNMENT EMPLOYEE IN A
NICE SAFE SPACE IF YOU'RE A
HEROIN ADDICT.
PEOPLE ARE GOING TO LOOK AT THAT
AND SAY IT'S NOT US.
ANY ISSUE OR NOT THE FUTURE
PENNSYLVANIA THAT I WANT TO LIVE
IN.
>> Sean: YOU CAN SEE IN THE
POLLING THAT OZ IS NARROWING IN
THE TRAFALGAR POLL.
YOU SEE ADAM LAXALT, J.D. VANCE
IS UP.
THINGS ARE CHANGING DRAMATICALLY
AND WE WILL FOLLOW IT.
I WILL NEVER CATCH UP WITH YOU I
THINK MORE MONEY WAS RAISED WHEN
YOU WERE SPEAKER WITH DEMOCRATS
USING YOUR NAME THAN -- I WILL
NEVER BE ABLE TO